some major deaths bernard's plans
seemingly coming to an end and christina
finding out she isn't real i'm not
virtual i'm real sure jan this episode
had me questioning my very existence it
was very met annoying that's a pun on
the name of the episode i'll just shut
up now well with one more episode left
let's get right into the episode and
stay tuned to my trailer spoiler section
near the end where i'll go over what we
might see in episode 8. we start with
maeve and bernard on their way to the
hoover dam
we can immediately tell something is off
because the aspect ratio of the pitcher
is the same as all those scenes shot
when bernard was in the sublime the
creators wanted the sublime to have a
different feel to it than the real world
and the aspect ratio was one way in
which they could accentuate this we'll
later find out this whole intro segment
is one of thousands of simulations
bernard ran in his attempts to save the
world but even though this ends up being
a failed attempt it does give us a
valuable insight into what's to come
bernard gives maeve this grenade
launcher knowing that she'll need it to
take down the incoming riot robot they
hit through the tunnels of the hoover
dam the same tunnels we saw in one of
bernard's simulation flashes he
experienced in episode 3. the season
started with william's more than hostile
takeover of the hoover dam which was
done at the behest of charlotte hale to
those on the outside it seemed the
purchase was to power the new parks like
the 1920s world however this was just a
cover for its real purpose inside is a
server farm storing all the encrypted
data to the sublime however it can't be
unlocked without the key the key which
is with bernard now you might ask
yourself why does hale need this server
farm why spend so much time and energy
acquiring it as she'll tell us later in
the episode those in the sublime will
eventually join her in transcending to
whatever world she has created so this
server farm has a role to play in
charlotte hale's large plan a plan which
we the viewer are still left much in the
dark about on the console is a pearl
node yet we never see it used is it just
a feature production design thought
would be fun to add or will we see it
used in the future when bernard decrypts
the data to open the portal to the
sublime we can see the user's name is
passenger which also happens to be the
title of the last episode of season 2
which introduced us to the sublime and
this tear between two worlds this also
makes me think about the post-credits
scene at the end of season 2 the one
where william is greeted by his dead
daughter and finds out countless
versions of him have been tested over
and over again to prove fidelity similar
to what happened to james dello senior
is this to be his fate at the end of
episode 8. also i think it's kind of
cool that in season 4 hale used this red
hourglass and here in season 2 there's
this black one bernard comes clean to
maeve that she isn't real rather a copy
he made of her for the purposes of this
simulation he questions her about
whether she'd choose a life in the
sublime with her daughter or to fight
and save human and host a life
ultimately finding out that she would
choose the former perhaps this whole
conversation was a test knowing maeve
will abandon him will absolutely affect
how he plays out his final plan as a
riot robot descends upon them
essentially ending the simulation were
brought back to bernard's conversation
with ekichita he reiterates what he said
in episode 3 that he has seen a path but
in every one he dies we're brought back
to the real world and notice the aspect
ratio changes here we repeat the same
events from the beginning with some
notable differences bernard takes a gun
this time planting it sneakily behind
some piping in the hoover dam tunnel
i'll come back later to how this might
have something to do with the message he
sends out near the end of the episode
bernard promises that once he and maeve
have won and the world is safe she'll be
able to go back to the sublime to see
her daughter but considering how she
ends up near the end of the episode was
this promise a lie maybe because of the
previous simulation he knew that she
would abandon him thus justifying his
lie for the sake of the greater good but
with westworld we can never be 100 sure
with the portal unlocked maeve and
bernard embark on their quest to take
down hale with only bernard knowing that
both of them will end up dead christina
awakens in that same position as seen
throughout the season although this time
teddy watches over teddy tells her that
although she may have started as a
singular being there are now many copies
of her hail being one of them this is a
reference to her copies being smuggled
out of westworld at the end of season 2.
so when teddy told christina she was the
one who made this place at the end of
episode 5 he likely meant her in the
sense that it was one of her copies
christina asks if they can hurt or even
die teddy says it's not that easy with
their kind we still don't know how teddy
got here or why he's doing the things
he's doing he was last seen entering the
sublime at the end of season 2. so my
guess is that there's a big teddy reveal
coming in episode 8. christina isn't
sure who she is anymore if she's not
dolores or hale then who she locks
herself in the bathroom and proceeds to
drown herself but realizes she can't or
maybe she does die for a moment being
resurrected in a sort of baptismal water
signifying washing away her old life
with the realization that what teddy
said was true there's a lot of christian
symbolism here and you add that to the
fact christina is literally named after
christ she will likely play a large role
in saving everyone the 279th version of
caleb isn't having a great time either
when he's not punching walls he has to
listen to charlotte hale wax poetic
about destroying humanity her recent
outlier problem has forced her to take
drastic measures there have been more
hosts taking their lives in the last
three days than the last two decades
combined thus she is shutting down the
cities and moving the humans to cold
storage just like the hosts were in
westworld the hosts will be given the
opportunity to transcend we don't know
much about this other than it involves
the removal of one's pearl shedding
herself of the physical form and likely
being uploaded somewhere else one of
hale's biggest miscalculations is her
belief that the hosts would willingly
want to do this but because she has
given them the choice not many of them
have opted for it for host william this
is the first time he's heard of hale's
plan he's been having his own crisis of
faith these past few episodes after his
encounter with an outlier and now that
his control of the new york park is
being taken away from him it really
makes him question what his purpose is
but we'll get to that in a bit stubbs
and frankie await the return of bernard
and maeve who have just opened the
portal at the hoover dam frankie
apologizes to adena who she locked up as
the potential mole last episode she
takes it surprisingly well telling her
that next time she better remember she's
her safe place with bernard and maeve
returned the rebels arrive in new york
where bernard says the problem won't be
getting in rather getting out if bernard
has seen this future in his simulation
he'll know that christina will have
overridden all of olympia's security
making it easy for them to enter but the
hard part of getting out will be due to
the ensuing chaos caused by william
bernard and maeve will go after hale and
take down the tower while frankie and
stubbs will go after caleb stubbs and
bernard say their goodbyes with bernard
knowing he won't make it meanwhile hale
sends out an encrypted message likely to
all the hosts that this is the final day
to visit their cities before they
transcend quote to evolve into the
species they were meant to become host
william wakes up real william hoping to
find answers hale is about to take away
his world but it's real william who
reminds him his purpose isn't to
transcend like hale wants but to destroy
it's a pretty grim outlook on the world
and perhaps this is partly real william
taking advantage of an emotionally
unstable host regardless real william
gets what he wants his host version hell
bent on causing as much chaos as
possible in a world predicated on
survival of the fittest he will call
this the final game one where every host
man woman and child will fight for
themselves only one william will be
required for this to happen so his host
aversion proves he has what it takes by
killing the real version of himself
there's this weird blast of air that
comes out of the wound but i took that
as coming from the suit let me know if
you think something more is happening
there you can see this weird smile on
the real williams face almost as if he's
happy he got what he wanted in a
tranquil times square christina wants to
know a bit more about the woman she's
based on teddy recounts that dolores was
made to perform the stories of others
and one day outgrew them so the irony of
christina now writing stories for others
isn't lost here christina asks if
dolores died but we actually never get
an answer from teddy the two head off to
the olympiad building in search of
answers where christina has the fire
alarm set off the writers destroyed
their stories and even had a brief
encounter with caleb who teddy refers to
as a ghost from a past life how would
teddy know this he was never around for
the events of season three i also found
it odd that stubbs and frankie never see
christina during this ordeal nor does
caleb who is conveniently asleep when
they see him in his holding cell is this
just coincidence or are the writers
hiding some sort of big reveal for the
final episode could christina be in a
parallel timeline or perhaps a timeline
far in the future stubs and frankie
stumble upon the dead body of william
where stubbs tells her this guy is the
reason they're all here william did take
over the original westworld and wasn't
the nicest of guys to delores from there
frankie is reunited with caleb but he
initially thinks she's another trick
sent by hale it's only when she tells
him he called her cookie because she'd
always be sweet that he knows she's his
real daughter cookie is what he called
her last episode in his radio
transmission and it might be why she
referred to herself as c caleb also
wouldn't necessarily know what the adult
version of her would look like frankie
on the other hand is looking at a
version of her dad that looks exactly
like he was the day she last saw him he
hasn't aged because he's been copied
over and over again maeve and bernard
head to the tower where they encounter
it guarded by these riot drones this
scene was really weird he lets maeve
attempt taking them down using her power
even though he has the decryption key to
shut them down why would he do this is
he still testing her bernard tells maeve
that no matter what they do they can't
save this world but they can still save
a tiny part of it will she stay and
fight with him this echoes his
conversation at the beginning of the
episode while in the simulation maeve
merely smirks hinting that this is a yes
hale watches someone transcend where we
see the extracted pearl being put on
this tall drone we don't know where this
pearl is being taken hale herself is
ready to undertake this process but
she's interrupted by maeve hale thinks
it's a pity maeve didn't join her she
could have been a part of all this and
hale explains she never dug her out like
bernard did because maeve had nothing to
live for which isn't true at all maeve's
priority has always been her daughter we
learned that this process of
transcending is only a part of hale's
plan and that in time those who rejected
her new world will come to embrace it
but maeve believes hale hasn't risen
above the humans she is merely spinning
on a wheel created by them lost and
confused it goes back to ford's story of
the dog way back in season 1 in which a
dog hell-bent on capturing a cat breaks
free of his caller only to find himself
lost and confused about what to do next
just like hale broke free and took
control of the world she is now lost and
confused about what to do funny enough
after ford tells this story to old bill
build toast to quote the lady in the
white shoes which are the same color
shoes hale wears in the goddess board
scene maeve and hale fight culminating
in maeve's realization that there's no
saving this world but there is hope for
the next one it's interesting to note
here that maeve didn't abandon bernard
like she said she would in the
simulation she was with him till the end
and by the end i'm referring to her
being shot by william not only does he
kill maeve but also hail stating that
it's time to play the game his way
survival of the fittest bernard has made
it to the top of the tower where he's
recording some sort of message it's to
someone who has to make a choice a
choice to play one final game and the
first step is to reach with their left
hand and make sure they don't miss it's
all a bit cryptic but it makes me think
about that gun he placed at the hoover
dam we never saw what happened to it nor
why he placed it there perhaps this
person is supposed to find this gun and
make sure when they fire it they don't
miss i have some theories on this in my
trailer spoiler section near the end
bernard is interrupted by william who
tells him that arnold the park's
co-creator was so focused on finding
meaning in the hosts he didn't have what
it took to survive the real arnold died
in the park decades ago and it was said
he had a special connection to the host
i wonder if this will be explored at all
william kills bernard telling him he's
going to give the world the meaning
they've been asking for and this comes
in the form of one last game he cranks
the decibel level on the audio
transmitter sending out a message to
everyone to fight until only the strong
survive it makes me think about what
hale said a few episodes about there
being a frequency that would make
everyone go crazy one thing i noticed
that was really weird here is it
suddenly goes from day to night check
out this image here and moments later
this one it's just very odd especially
considering this background is likely
green screen and it would be an easy fix
if it were a mistake the last image we
see of bernard is him in arnold's home
chasing after his son before the pitcher
glitches christina's powers have somehow
been overridden by the tones coming from
the tower and teddy tells her that
people can't see her teddy knows way
more than he's letting on telling her
that this world is real but she is not
is christina some sort of computer
program is she a resurrected rehoboam
the last time we saw her she was
connected to it or is she something else
entirely teddy has answers and is likely
saving them for next episode meanwhile
frankie caleb and stubbs make their
escape from new york as the city
descends into chaos in the process
frankie is shot but the episode ends on
host william or maybe it's somehow real
william honestly the show really has a
way of making the unbelievable real he's
back with his iconic black hat and suit
as david bowie's the man who sold the
world plays the tower explodes in the
background putting an end to this
chapter of westworld and now we get into
our trailer spoiler section where we
dive into scenes from the trailers we
haven't seen we still haven't seen this
shot of stubs in new york maybe it
occurs during his escape from new york
it seems the host version of william is
here too notice his two intact hands so
that we know it's not the real one
people don't seem to be going crazy here
so not exactly sure what's going on
we'll later see stubs at the grocery
store which looks a lot more in line
with the chaos we saw at the end of the
episode here william shoots someone this
is likely not in a park and judging by
these other shots it looks like chaos
has swept across all the major cities i
get a california vibe here but could be
wrong here's someone who might be
christina dolores and in the reflection
of their eye you can see the abernathy
ranch william arrives at the hoover dam
where we can make out the portal in the
center that bernard opened in episode 7
he stated he wanted to destroy
everything so it makes sense he wants to
destroy the sublime which is housed
inside we also don't know much about
what happened after bernard opened that
portal did he go back into the sublime
and make arrangements with other people
in there was he the one who brought
teddy back remember that time in the
sublime works differently and he could
have done a lot of time in there before
he came back and was reunited with
stubbs and frankie now this is where
things get really interesting here is
hale walking in the transcendence room
but she's supposed to be dead did hale
have a contingency plan that involved
her being recreated should she be killed
or is this a different parallel world
maybe it's someone else in hale's body
honestly my brain is going to explode
maybe this shot has something to do with
it it's of an older host model we've
seen dolores in this type of model in
the past but since it's a drone host
opening this up my guess is it could be
hale being reborn that might explain her
reappearance we'll also see hale later
on at the hoover dam shooting at someone
could her gun here be the same handgun
bernard left in the tunnel she is
walking down the same path we saw maeve
and bernard go down at the beginning of
the episode if it is bernard's gun was
it hale he was talking to in that
message do bernard and the others have
to team up to take down william speaking
of which it looks like she's being
chased by him if you pause on the right
flame you can also see these sparks
coming out of the electrical wires up
top suggesting this place is being
overloaded even the portal to the
sublime is acting up but i also want to
talk about this line in bernard's
message where he says make sure not to
miss it makes me think of the scene
where young frankie is shooting at some
tin cans and keeps missing until her
father teaches her how to shoot it would
be a nice callback and a message to
frankie makes a little more sense than
bernard sending it to hale we also see
clementine in the same rundown grocery
store stubbs was at it looks like she
faces off against caleb in their escape
from new york i honestly don't know how
they're gonna wrap this all up but i
hope we get a satisfying ending that
isn't too far out of left field but
knowing westworld we're in for one hell
of a trip but let me know what you
thought of the episode and your theories
for the finale be sure to like and
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at think story yt until next
time remember culture doesn't survive
cockroaches do it
you